look we're going back to the um everyone
can call the police I just don't think
it's that easy I just think if you're
gonna come on a podcast and say that you
were abused like I hope you have a
police report to back it up because
otherwise
I I yeah yeah I don't know your life
official but I'm just saying like in
that case I don't think it's easy to say
you know if I get punched I can call the
police when maybe that person I haven't
been physically abused but if that
person's threatening me my child my my
life my I just don't think it's that
easy to say I just think abuse as a
whole is someone's throwing my child I
would I would more so want to go I
understand but before you get the chance
to call to that police how do you know
that your life can't be taken or there's
so much manipulation and
then as soon as I was in a safe
situation I know I understand but
sometimes the did the police do
everything to guard you don't do the
police have said 24 hours surveillance
on y'all don't have guns here so it's
better yeah that's the problem there's a
whole lot that's the problem
is my issue is when women come forward
and say they were abused and they have
no evidence to back it up and they can
defame a man and assassinate his
character well where people know who you
dated and you have no evidence that it
happened so then you get girls coming on
the show there's no proof of it no
defamation and as a whole is I think
that could go both ways like if it's a
guy saying that about another guy yeah
and it's not gender thing and yeah but
guys don't do that in general they
probably do they probably do slam each
other this they don't you
don't come on here and do that I've done
the show for a year but I'm saying I I
talk to people on the street who talks
to more people than me and and I I I
could see that
to anybody I make friends with everyone
I love it but yeah I don't think we
should should victim blame or like not
believe like women when it comes to
situations like this but one thing Pearl
said that was actually really really um
important is if um I'm with my partner
and we've had a fight why am I gonna go
Reporter as an abuse should be reported
as a fight that's one thing that like a
lot of women get away with as well if
it's a fight it's a fight and that's
when they're taking the reports now and
they're now realizing actually so did
you hit him back and then now they're
stuttering I hate that in women because
firstly your story you just know already
you being a woman you've got that upper
hand so that's why you went forward and
reported it as an abuse from the get-go
that's the that pisses me off go
and say we had a fight
and then tell them a story so it's for
the is the police the police job to
decide exactly what's going to be done
you know with the evidence and the proof
and everything but most times they get
back together so because there are women
who will absolutely
go to a go to the police or whatever and
Report their boyfriend or whatever for
abuse
purely out of spite yeah because and it
is it is sickness it is sick and it's
twisted but they do it because they know
they can do it they know they can get
away with it because there's zero
repercussion it's not a lot it's um come
on Sterling it's probably a lot more
than you think
I would not trust there's gonna be no
way to measure that statistically you
can't because
um
but you're not going to know who's like
like how are you gonna know how many
women went and lied because it's based
on evidence is there anyone and the
woman decided because women decide not
to prosecute all the time
I mean you can also look at this case
you can also see cases that come in the
media like um footballers there's yeah I
mean there's there's one that's coming
to my head it was that college
um in the U.S where there was a girl who
said a guy raped her and
um he they ended up pulling the security
footage from the bar and she was pulling
his head in to kiss her she was pulling
him back to the dorm and she said that
he graped her right and he still got
kicked out of college yeah even even
with the footage even with the
footballers like when um they have this
um sa assault cases and then like
everyone's on the edge of the sea
waiting for the outcome and you hear
that it was actually a lie it's just so
heartbreaking in my head I'm thinking
they should be the women should be
arrested because you you some people
have spent time in prison like in jail
and not the whole career destroyed
because someone's lie and then they just
go ahead and be like oh yeah yeah the
women who falsely accuse men of
greatness should be arrested
you're stealing someone's life yeah 100
time in their life so I do believe that
if you lie about something like that you
should get exact the same amount of time
they would have gotten if they did it
but that'll never happen you know why
that's newsworthy though
you know why why because it's not that
common
you know why female grape is not as
newsworthy because it is so common
female grape is definitely newsworthy no
if somebody was falsely accused that's
newsworthy because it's not common if
it's something common why would it be in
the news because it would be Avenue and
all the time we'd be used to it
right like which is what's happening
with women women are being sexually Fair
fade more regularly than women are a
defamating character so that that's why
it's newsworthy because it's weird and
we don't like it
I mean guys get dragged through the
media all the time with these
accusations yeah yeah it's newsworthy
because it's strange yeah but they're
getting they're getting dragged for the
if the guy is if the guy has any degree
sorry well if a guy has any degree of
notoriety that's all of the news
instantly like if I would I would argue
that if that's happening to a man with
money status and fame what happens to
the average guy those are guys with the
money to defend themselves what happens
to a guy that has no money if anything I
think when you see those Fringe cases in
the media especially to man like
um that that are especially that have
money status and power it's like
and a regular guys can kind of get a
voice at all that's interesting and even
that you'll lose your um your way of
income anyways because most times they
get they get dropped reputation's gone
yeah your reputation is gone even even
in a company a girl can go to HR and get
a guy fired with no you know Pro there's
no judge and jury there but you can just
go to HR and get him fired and say he
did something with no proof and that's
never going to go to court that's never
going to be in the news I think it's
less than 10 of great cases are false
accusations
I'd love you to Google it please can we
have like that Jamie though
how would they know that I check it how
would they know who's being falsely
accused so it would be a case of is
there any evidence and obviously it
would fall apart or maybe it was like
redacted because what percent of what
percent of rape accusations even go to
trial I can't say that word yeah yeah
okay okay what percent of rate
accusations actually go to trial
very low so so you could argue that
they're all false I'm not saying they
are but I'm saying like how would you
know so I guess in 10 and circumstances
around it right right but that's that's
my whole point 10 are proven
but you you can't say out of the rest
who's not proven no you're right it's
circumstantial right so you need to look
into it father you're so right well and
if you look at like Harvey Weinstein or
some of these other big guys that got me
too you have these women who claim like
decades ago oh I was a victim all this
was happening to me and in many cases
they're saying I love you Harvey I love
you very much they're sending him emails
they're saying how much they love them
they keep coming back and coming back
and coming back and I feel like
especially lately
they will call it a grape if a woman has
sex with a guy and then like regrets it
the next day or a year later or two
years later they're very liberal with
the accusations when we think about it I
feel like we we all know what we think
of which is like somebody is forcibly
penetrated with physical violence
against their will that actually isn't I
don't believe what happens in the
majority of cases usually it's something
like well I was coerced well oh I was
just so Charmed sometimes there's even
verbal consent given but they'll say
well I was under duress and you know
that gets a little bit tricky it makes
it a little bit more complicated because
I think we would all agree that the
violent kind of Confrontation that we
all think about is totally wrong it
should never happen that's often not the
case when we're talking about
accusations and the courts and the media
typically believe the women sometimes
when there's no evidence very little
evidence or sometimes even contradictory
evidence and that that's like the new
reality what if it was the contrary
wouldn't that be a shitload worse what
would be the contrary the contrary is if
we just believed men outright and they
just went willingness who's more likely
to lie yeah but that is making an
assumption right there you're making an
assumption that the vast majority men
you just said if it was reversed yeah
things would be a show I don't
think I really don't think they would in
the courts it would be a bit of a I
mean in public like the society could be
better actually yeah that sounds like a
good idea
in Sharia law that you need for those
for those particular accusations you
need like what I think it's three or
four women's testimonies to one man's
testimony for certain things like that
but women are less likely to commit
violent acts so am I right or am I wrong
with them
sorry what were you saying just saying
women are literally almost by half
less likely to commit violent acts of
crime which means that if we believe the
gender that commits more of it moreover
than the gender that commits less of it
what we're doing is just encouraging but
women lie more yeah uh yeah fair enough
so we shouldn't believe it I think
you're gorgeous too sexy it's true
I'm saying it's true that women lie more
that's why they should be looking for a
virgin pipe town
that Ship Sails also so heavy I'm
curious have you found it yet no not yet
I used to look him well do you know what
do you know why it's okay for him to
look it because he's a man the older he
gets them and he's only here
I'm 24. oh you're a baby bless you yeah
take your time
I'm also Married to the Game okay I'm
married to what I'm doing lovely